foreign
just got a taste of the button today
Callan got the shut up button I was
waiting I I somebody told me right
before the show and I'm like please
someone get that clip yeah so for those
again we've talked about it again but we
bought your old clips but there is uh
Dave Landau said on those the Michael
malice show right he said that uh that
Trotter has to shut up whatever Landau
signing you're being too funny for him
because Crowder has to get the last
words so I haven't seen this obviously
we just got this now here we go
[Music]
right back
oh
yeah ladies
lights
right it's like it's it's like being in
Matt Lauer's office
I thought that would get more but I
guess the shockingness No Mercy Mercy
what you said was funny but you would
think after he was called out for it
that he wouldn't keep doing it also why
would you put the button in such an
obvious Place why would you oh my god
Marsh Marsh all I want right now now
that we know where it's located now
there's going to be a spurg that's going
to go back and do a super cut of every
time he does that because that's
probably something we've never noticed
you know what I mean
look there it is right there can we see
it one more time sure this is the best
ever you see if if like
huh
hold on I'm back a bit sorry also ladies
eat this [__] voice
I bet you probably think that look if
you want to be in a place where kids
your own parents can force them to keep
them up too
you're not funny Crowder you're a
[__] stupid hack
dude imagine like
like I understand sometimes like you're
trying to make a point whatever you know
but like could you imagine if I was like
no Royce you need to shut up well Dirty
Boys
come on hey let me cook yeah
you're like what the [__] you made me
shut up for this can I say something
that I think is an objective truth as
much as we've made fun of a calendar we
make fun of Callan Callan is a billion
times funnier than Crowder will ever be
I feel so bad for him I can't believe it
I can't believe we feel bad for Brian
Callan Brian buddy
buddy we and honestly man like imagine
going from working with one [__] to
going working another [__] you're
like you're you you just jump on every
sinking ship huh
holy [__] Arbiter of death Jesus
[__] Christ so what happens every
time Rumble signs somebody big they just
[__] Fall Apart
[Laughter]
ladies I'll watch this over and over
again I'll watch this over and over
again
you [__] sociopath Brian Collins like
the dog at an old folks home
yeah you know what the best part is is
that Carolyn's got a temper too so you
know he's [__] stewing about this
you know he sits there and [__] stews
every time that light comes on
are you telling me
that over the years merch and I have
done shows together with people before I
mean all of that and it's like all it
takes is like as long as you're not an
egotistical person and you're fine when
letting somebody else be funny
doing this isn't that hard you don't
need a shut up light you know what I'm
saying as long as you don't mind letting
somebody else on your Show Shine
you know yeah it's just being smart and
being lazy beep
no but that's what he's doing right yeah
this would be like having a shut up Alex
Jones button and then bringing them on
there what are you [__]
we're literally we're the only ones that
every time we've had Alex on like we
just let him run wild we don't even talk
to the point where sometimes people go
like he didn't let you talk I'm like
yeah that's the point yeah you hear us
talk every [__] day yeah you know
what we sound like we'll be back
tomorrow 4pm yeah let Alex Cook yeah you
know and to be fair he let us do his
third hour so we're even
there you go this is this is so glad
that that came in this is brilliant this
is brilliant you [__] sociopath you
maniac nobody likes you anymore Crowder
you lost everything
now here's the truth and we said this
before
he'll be fine though you know when I
said lost to everything I'm in
credibility but what I mean is he'll be
fine he's gonna he'll he's got a 30 drop
of people the new cycle is going to pass
unless something really terrible comes
out again these people are gonna forget
it forgive them and they're going to
still listen to Crowder and Crowder's
numbers will be back to normal within
what do you say about six months uh I
don't know if they'll ever be
necessarily back to normal or close to
normal but close to yeah but he's still
gonna lose a few couple tree bucks right
yeah they'll be 100 back to normal and
like
a year or two yeah give or take because
he he'll pick up new [__] retards
they always pick up new retards we do